oh really okay
should i do it okay i gotta do it for
the content do it for the content all
right fine
how much how much have you studied i'm
not much wow
the only thing i've studied is uh i
think bishop two
and then c three
okay okay this is all prepped
yeah i think i should not to make you
more scared so
be careful
this is another time where i want to
invent my own idea but go for it i might
already mess this up
oh no my bishop yeah i wonder if i could
like do something to get you out of
theory i think the time for that
is now yeah
literally inventing my own opening right
now
literally i know i know
i'm playing sub part oh my bishop
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
what is going on i used
a funny line where you get your
[Applause]
okay we should play practical chess
[Applause]
i wasn't sure
[Applause]
uh this is the park like
a castle it's so great
no i think it's actually very standard
i have a lot of scariness here
the best defense is offense
that's defense is really getting upon
you
no offense
i have the sideways back
[Music]
office
yolo you only live once
i'm scared though
i don't think i want to take that
or the hard way
[Music]
my
right
[Music]
there's no time for either of us
[Music]
i'm trying to use that e8 square
leverage you're gonna make me here but
it's it's basically one move microwave
[Applause]
oh beautiful beautiful yeah no
so what would so bishop about three
wasn't good i can't that twin d3 is
winning okay
yeah yeah that's what i played right
yeah i think in the
in the middle probably if i was actually
in hindsight maybe maybe you should play
rook takes d5 like uh
when i played uh these are playing
instead of playing uh
c4 no what was the pawn already on yeah
well you played nice
earlier there was a rope takes d5 if i
take it
g3 yeah g3 is really comp i'm not sure
what happens i'm not sure what's that
crazy position yeah you went into like a
safer line what's this what's the bishop
takes before in life yeah bishop g4 or
g3 are the two
right g3 then you go back and then you
like there's a line where
uh it's like i can't avoid some
deep preparation either way that's right
but i made it up on the spot this is
this thing
that was good it's a huge uh it's a huge
risk though thanks to
going to a stafford line against
stafford but it's great it's good for
content it's good for people
appreciate it i know you better get
better appreciate it just kidding
uh all right